[Music]
russ is with us russ is in south bend
indiana hi russ welcome to the ramsey
show
hello dave appreciate what you're doing
god bless you sir you too sir what's up
and uh well i'm in my fpu i'm uh last
night we did steps four through seven
uh my situation is this uh recently came
into some money through the sale of my
house
uh recently got married about nine days
ago
and a couple years ago i was not in this
good financial position and i took out a
debt uh reduction or debt negotiation
contract
with this organization i don't know now
i'm i'm paying off everything in fact um
we wrote a check today to pay off my
wife's uh house
wow that's out of the way we have the uh
the emergency fund she have a separate
house than you
no no i sold my house
and now i'm moving in with her
y'all just got married okay yeah nine
days ago okay okay
so my question is this
how do i handle this debt reduction
thing that's hanging over my head i'd
like to get out of it completely but i'm
in this contract it involves monthly
payments i call them today and ask them
is it better for me to just go to the
creditors myself directly and write them
checks or do i hang in with you they
indicated you know should hang in with
them well yeah worse yeah
well yeah i know like asking a dog if
it's hungry
should we continue to collect fees from
you or not let me think about this
yeah no you need to and you don't have
to cancel the contract you just stop
giving them money it'll all end
just stop giving them money yeah yeah
stop stop giving that company money that
that's doing this um debt repayment plan
how many creditors are involved
well now it's down to three originally
it started out with about a dozen okay
we'll just call those three
and negotiate a deal with each one of
them
were you behind with them in this
process probably
yeah and of course since i got in this
uh this debt reduction thing a couple
years ago there's been no phone calls no
harassment nothing let's call them up
here just call them up and ask for uh
and say okay i'm gonna i'll i'm in a
position to pay this off if you give me
a deal
now what kind of deal can we make
okay now one of the things that was told
me today when i called this debt
reduction company is well you're taking
a big risk if you do that they might get
aggressive with you we've got you
covered by this uh litigation firm
that'll stand up for you if they do get
that kind of aggressive so it kind of
scared me
but you're saying
just don't pay them and talk to the
creditors don't worry i guess huh
you have the money to pay him
i do
why would you worry about being
aggressive
well it's been a long time since they've
received a payment from me i don't know
it's okay you're you're the customer on
the account they love money
and if you call them up and go how much
can i pay you
i don't think they're i don't think you
have to worry about them being
aggressive you also have this awesome
feature on your phone called uh do not
answer you can hit that too yeah they're
not gonna get aggressive that's that's
just company god man these guys are evil
not only not only did not only they use
a scare tactic to keep you on the hook
russ you're talking about these guys
like they're your friends yeah
and like they don't have a con like they
don't have a conflict of interest in
this stupid butt advice they're giving
you
they want to keep you on the line they
want to keep you keep you paying them
fees
and you're saying just stop paying them
how do you get away with that
you stop paying the company that you're
talking to on the phone that's giving
you this bad advice instead you call the
creditors and you ask each of the three
creditors a simple question
i'm going to write a check and pay this
off today if you will make me a deal
get what's the deal
and send that to me an email in written
form you keep that in writing and you
send them that money
okay it's and it goes away there's not
just that simple it's only they're only
going to get aggressive the the
creditors the three creditors if they
don't get money
do you have enough to pay all three of
them off yeah
yeah i do yeah
congratulations you're gonna be a free
man today yeah it'll take you it'll take
you two weeks to get through the crap
here but but um you're gonna have to
have a you know back and forth
conversation with them and force them to
give it to you in writing do not give
them money till you get it in writing
and do not give them electronic access
to your checking account but this
company is not your friend
they're debt con solidation companies
that's what we call them
and do i negotiate with these creditors
or just give them what they're asking
for i i would i would say uh what is the
balance
and what kind of deal can you make me
okay
because these are all bad debts
that you've been paying payments on bad
debts
they would love to get your butt off
their books
okay and they probably will give you a
an offer of 50 to 70 cents on the dollar
when one phone call
well that sounds pretty good yeah
of whatever the balance is do you have
any idea what the actual balance is
today
yes okay so you can you can kind of
you've got some basis point to know if
the company this creditor when you call
them is lying to you then so you can go
okay wait a minute the number i've got
is this what are you showing is the
balance
and if i wrote a check today and paid
this off what kind of deal would you
give me
because i'm thinking about doing that
okay if you give me a good enough deal
they've probably turned this over to
collection companies and that's probably
who i'll be talking to doesn't matter
they're the same thing they want money
okay everyone here wants your money if
they if they sold the debt they sold it
for a nickel on the dollar
and so they sold a thousand dollar debt
for 50 bucks
and if that's who you're talking to that
bought your thousand dollar debt for 50
bucks you're gonna get a really good
deal when you do what i do when you do
what i just told you to do
so
dude you are uh you act like that these
guys uh have magic powers over this
other company they don't have magic
powers they're just doofuses or if it
sounds like you feel like you fell into
a river and these guys showed up on a
night on like horses with
i don't know swords and things and
pulled you out of the river and saved
you
and
they didn't they didn't they didn't you
were in the river and they threw you a
concrete block so here hold this
okay that's
and oh by the way there's a fee for the
block there's a few for the block
yeah so no these are not your friends
this is the slimy i've never heard
somebody with that level of like
his heartbeats for this company no he's
just he's worried they they they'll
scare you huh they took care of him when
he was scared yeah he they got the
creditors off of him that's right and
they got a plan and he's just been
working that plan he didn't want to
upset that apple cart yeah and then they
pushed on that button because they knew
that was the button to use
and that that's keeping him in the
saddle here which is a bad plan
yeah call the three creditors get you a
deal write them a check get it in
writing no electronic access to your
checking account
get it in writing
no electronic access to your checking
account and you got a deal and you'll be
out of this in within two weeks
this is the ramsey show